peu
nantes châteaubourg gonds un aéroport
qui existent situé près de la ville
assez bien aménagé mais un peu bruyant
et bientôt trois petits à 20 km au nord
de nantes la campagne des communes
paisible une zone agricole où l'élevage
marche bien où les agriculteurs sont
assez prospère
[Musique]
on aurait pu remplacer château bourgon
par un grand aéroport situé entre rennes
et nantes pour desservir tout l'ouest
on a choisi le site de notre dame des
landes vigneux-de-bretagne grand champ
est très fière sur cette zone on
aménagera peut-être à l'avenir
l'aéroport ouest atlantique
cette passion s'il est intéressante
vis-à-vis de nantes
elle est aussi intéressante vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble des villes de l'ouest
dans la mesure où on peut penser que à
partir de 1990 par exemple 1980 c'est
d'ailleurs en drôme pourra servir à des
liaisons beaucoup plus lointaine alors à
ce moment là on a calculé par un certain
nombre de procédés sur lequel nous nous
étendrons pas que la situation de notre
dame des landes était relativement
proche de ce qu'on peut appeler le
centre de gravité de l'ensemble des
grandes villes de l'ouest
la position de la municipalité notre
dame des landes
nous allons pris une délibération en
date du 29 septembre 72 et nous avions
émis un avis favorable
[Musique]
la décision n'a pas été facile à prendre
le conseil municipal de notre dame des
landes manquer d'éléments de jugement il
a suivi l'avis favorable donné par les
autres communes situées sur la zone et
en particulier vigneux de bretagne
des réserves ont été émises par les élus
locaux par souci de protéger des
agriculteurs et aussi les riverains du
futur aéroport
dans un premier temps de préfet de
région a signé la création de la zone où
sera situé l'aéroport la zad monsieur
guillard explique pourquoi il y était
favorable
pourquoi me demander et bien parce que
nous avons pensé puisque nous à dire
quand même 14 ans alors pendant les
quatorze années
quand le décret de zad ou l'arrêter
sachs a pris car sur le préfet de
loire-atlantique préfet de région les
agriculteurs concernés en quand même 14
ans pour soit se reconvertir ouvert
leurs positions votre maison ne sera pas
sur la zone de l'aérodrome votre maison
là où à n'importe quel poste plus au
dessus et grenoble et qu'est ce que ça
vous fait vous de savoir qu'il y aura
des syndromes ici alors on aurait tant
aimé par mais qu'est ce qui va se passer
pour vous de partir pour partir chercher
un autre notre endroit pour habiter et
où est ce que vous pensez à les
surveiller parce qu'on est originaire
d'avignon
pas très loin de toute façon ao non à
leur secours n'a en aimerait c'est pour
les enfants ça fait plus tard pour les
enfants que pour nous mêmes
17 exploitations se trouve sur la zone
les agriculteurs ils sont jeunes deux
sur trois en moins de 50 ans un comité
de défense des riverains a été créé il
se demande si l'aéroport serait
justifiée avec une crise de l'énergie
une retraite aussi que des routes
départementales soit supprimer un jour
les raisons qui poussent à faire cet
aéroport son intérêt régional plus que
local c'est un endroit me devrait
prendre le remplacement de l'aérodrome
de chanteloup gonds lequel peut se
développer encore avec les éléments
actuels jusqu'au environ 290 sans trop
de difficultés mais à partir de même de
1990 en raison d'une part de l'extension
du trafic et en raison d'autres par des
nuisances dégagée par ce trafic sur
l'agglomération nantaise il notamment
sur la partie sud ouest de
l'agglomération nantaise
il sera nécessaire de déplacer
l'aéroport de trouver un site un peu
plus éloignés quoique suffisamment
proche permettant à la fois d'éviter des
nuisances et de permettre un trafic bien
plus considérables en escomptant 1985 un
trafic de l'ordre de 1 million un
million trois cent mille passagers pour
se faire une idée de ce qu'est ce trafic
l'authentic de lyon est actuellement de
l'ordre de 1 million de passagers ce
terrain est exceptionnellement situé
dans une zone d'une part où
l'urbanisation est très faible et où
d'autre part où la direction des pistes
d'envol qui sont à peu près dans la
direction des vents dominants c'est à
dire est ouest ne risque pas n'importe
ecobiz ans sur des sur des territoires
où vraiment la danse une population est
relativement faible
si vous êtes toujours là ça va vous
gêner votre foyer du coup vous ne
resterez pas quand j'entendrai le
vacarme faudrait le camp j'ai été trop
laborieux son poing dans les airs et
elles ont très tôt que prévu
non
sur le plan aviation aéronautique est ce
qu'on connaît les zones de bruit de
notre dame des landes on t'a fait du
futur aéroport
on les connaît il ya des zones type
effectivement oui et tout dépensé zones
sont directement fonction du trafic ce
qui fait que on ne peut pas déterminer
longtemps l'avant ce nom une courbe
données sera toujours bonne mais on peut
pas dire à quelle échéance
mais parce que c'est important dans la
mesure où des gens voudraient par
exemple s'installer construire dans une
zone assez proche
si cela se trouve dans une zone trop
proche de l'aéroport
ils ne peuvent pas le faire oui mais
enfin je peux vous confirmer d'une part
que la zad est assez large justement été
conçue largement l'aérodrome lui-même ne
nécessiterait que 600 ou 650 hectares et
on en met le double dans la za justement
pour protéger aussi des voisins
[Musique]
l'aéroport ouest atlantique desservirait
tout l'ouest il assurerait un trafic
international
on y installerait une piste d'envol puis
deux et peut-être trois un jour en
fonction de l'évolution du trafic
château boudon serait alors réservé à
l'aviation d'affaires
ce que vous en pensez des aérodromes
comme ça qui vient de se mettre à la
campagne engagez vous voulez il ya du
chômage
nous devons pouvoir en occuper la
domaine ya du boulot à faire
c'est une porte ouverte pour l'avenir il
c'est une des portes vertes n'est plus
intéressante à mon avis pour le
décollage de l'ensemble de l'ouest
français on prendrait peut-être l'avion
si vous êtes toujours dans la la la la
la
je ne lui ai pas demandé et de
recrutement dans mon lit alors l'avion
où l'on
l'aéroport international non pérenne ce
projet qui semblait aux oubliettes vient
de ressurgir orange élément nouveau une
volonté commune des deux présidents des
conseils généraux d'ille et vilaine et
de loire-atlantique de mener à son terme
le projet de notre dame des landes mais
l'horizon reste lointain on parle des
années 2025 ou 2030 il y a trois mois
châteaubourg devenu aéroport
international de nantes atlantique
la nouvelle aérogare était inaugurée
preuve de l'extension du premier
aéroport de l'ouest avec un million de
passagers en un an
châteaubourg on est le huitième en
france 1 100 millions de francs
d'investissements ont été réalisés
depuis 1987 pour le développement de son
trafic international
mais à l'horizon 2028 nantes atlantique
sera probablement saturé avec un trafic
de 4 millions de passagers
d'où la nécessité d'une nouvelle
plateforme ne s'agit pas de concurrencer
nantes atlantique bien entendu mais de
tenir compte de l'évolution du trafic
deuxième millénaire est d'être prêt à
répondre dans le cadre de l'arc
atlantique un grand aéroport
recouvre encore une fois deux régions
voire plus depuis 15 ans le département
de loire atlantique constitue une
réserve foncière à notre dame des landes
un site nettement plus proche de nantes
que de rennes
pourtant l'île et vilaine avait déjà
apporté son soutien au projet l'an passé
pierre méhaignerie est en effet
favorable à un aéroport du grand ouest
dans la perspective de l'arc atlantique
même arena ce vieux projet vu d'un oeil
favorable par la chambre de commerce
l'aéroport de saint jacques n'a pas de
réelle vocation internationale
à mon sens cet aéroport devrait être un
point de départ d'un grand pôle
d'affaires entre rennes et nantes ou
aéroport international mais
nécessairement garde éclatement tgv mais
également poule d'affaires c'est-à-dire
des bureaux c'est à dire du tertiaire
ceux ci auraient un rôle s'ils voulaient
au niveau de l'aménagement du territoire
et de la dynamique du grand ouest
européen très important en fait
l'aéroport et n'est plus perturbé
actuellement par la concurrence du tgv
que par la perspective lointaine d'un
nouvel aéroport au nord de nantes une
plateforme de dimension européenne qui
pourrait voir le jour dès l'an 2000 si
les autres collectivités suivent le
futur aéroport international de notre
dame des landes à quelques 30 kilomètres
au nord de nantes pourrait ouvrir dans
quelques années peut-être dans 15 ans
c'est ce qui étudie en effet en ce
moment le conseil général de loire
atlantique
si tout va bien début du chantier notre
dame des landes dans huit ans aussi
extraordinaire que cela puisse paraître
c'est peut-être ici derrière moi sur ses
terres de notre dame des landes que se
poseront en l'an 2007 les premiers
avions gros porteurs
invocation de desserte à la fois inter
régional pour tout le grand ouest mais
aussi c'est important internationale ça
fait belle lurette qu'il est question de
ce projet porté à bout de bras notamment
par les présidents des conseils généraux
de loire-atlantique et d'ille-et-vilaine
charles-henri de cossé brissac et pierre
méhaignerie cependant dès 1975 on
assistait à une mobilisation du monde
rural riverains de notre dame des landes
contre ce projet d'aménagement de
plateforme aéroportuaire sur quelques
milles hectares aujourd'hui qu'en est il
à l'heure qu'il est bon aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que
tout le monde a plus ou moins laissé
tomber quoi enfin dans les idées ou à
disons ça changeait quoi on s'est bien
rendu compte qu'on peut pas aller contre
le progrès c'est dommage pour la qualité
de l'environnement de qualité de vie en
général vers des nuisances sonores
les premières conclusions du comité
d'étude sont tombés elle laisse
apparaître qu'on pourrait évoluer à
terme vers une saturation de trafic sur
l'aéroport de nantes atlantique et que
ce château bourgon d'où la nécessité de
prévoir avec une décennie davance la
réalisation d'un nouvel aéroport et
d'éviter ainsi des investissements
doubles emplois sur celui de
nantes-atlantique
c'est une décision définitive été prise
en 1997 le début des travaux
interviendrait alors en l'an 2000 reste
cependant encore à connaître la position
d'un acteur essentiel du dossier l'état
les habitants de notre dame des landes
connais ton t-il un jour cette scène
d'un avion de ligne qui survolent leur
clocher avant d'atterrir c'est quasi
certain
mais contrairement aux ambitions
nantaise du début des années 90 d'en
faire un outil international est une
plateforme grant west le projet apparaît
désormais à nuancer ce qui est clair
d'abord c'est qu'avec l'agrandissement
de roissy n'en a perdu pour l'instant
peut être plus que chartres un appui
éventuel de l'état et donc une dimension
internationale
ensuite à côté de ça l'augmentation
régulière du trafic de nantes atlantique
fait que sa construction devient
inéluctable après 2005 mais avec dans
l'immédiat le seul caractère régional
nous avons une aérogare qui est
perpendiculaire à la piste donc nous
sommes au plein donc n'ont pratiquement
on ne peut plus s'agrandir
soissons ça serait uniquement en à un
agrandissement des aérogares mais pas
les pistes à les pistes ça c'est
impossible
les pistes on a la voix ferrée d'un côté
on a lac de grand lieu de l'autre et
salaires et la commune de saint-aignan
donc on ne peut plus agrandi seulement
voilà tout irait bien si ce projet qui
affiche bientôt 20 ans avait continué
dans les mêmes termes qu'au départ un
projet interrégional d'aménagement
mains du grand ouest que les conseils
généraux de loire-atlantique et
d'ille-et-vilaine appelait alors de
leurs voeux pierre méhaignerie et luc de
joie était tellement en phase à l'époque
qu'ils avaient même lancé ensemble
l'étude de faisabilité du projet or
aujourd'hui seuls le conseil général de
loire atlantique a continué et des
centaines d'hectares ont été acquises
sur la commune de notre dame des landes
faut entre 1000 et 12 cents hectares
pour arriver à construire totalement
l'aéroport et aujourd'hui nous
approchons en propriété des 900 hectares
par conséquent ça ne sera pas
l'acquisition des terrains qui créera un
problème quelconque à mon sens est
d'ailleurs c'est notre gros avantage
d'avoir su anticiper depuis beaucoup
d'années anticipée ou précédé pour
rendre irréversible si personne ne
conteste que nantes soit aujourd'hui le
pôle numéro 1 de l'ouest rennes ne fait
que du trafic d'affaires
en revanche la dimension internationale
du futur aéroport laisse perplexe je ne
crois pas aux ambitions internationales
de notre dame des landes
l'expérience a déjà prouvé que des
essais de développement de lignes au
départ de nantes vers l'amérique du nord
ont connu des échecs retentissants
finalement c'est moins la proximité du
futur aéroport avec nantes qui critique
et que de sentiments breton d'investir
chez les autres sans contrepartie notre
dame des landes se fera mais au donnant
donnant
bonjour à tous c'est donc maintenant
officiel le futur héros pour
international du grand ouest verra bien
le jour un autre dame des landes le
projet date de trente ans il devrait
être une réalité à l'horizon 2010 il
devrait se substituer à l'actuel
aéroport de nantes et devrait être
dimensionnée pour 4 à 5 millions de
passagers
retour sur une annonce politique avec le
trône elle sans concurrencer les
aéroports bretons existants notre dame
des landes basé entre rennes et nantes
est maintenant définitivement lancée cet
aéroport international renforcera les
aéroports bretons sur les liaisons
nationales et transversale le futur
aéroport intercontinental vise un
potentiel de 4 millions de passagers
dans l'ouest principaux aéroports
régionaux seront développés en respect
des contraintes environnementales
parce qu'il constitue un verrat
véritable atout d'aménagement du
territoire et développement économique
et donc les capacités par exemple du
futur aéroport de nantes notre dame des
landes seront adaptés à sa vocation de
plateforme d'échangés entre l'ouest et
les autres pôles notamment européens
le futur aéroport de l'ouest doit
maintenant être étudié par les élus
régionaux de bretagne et des pays de la
loire
la consultation va être lancée jusqu'au
15 avril pour une décision définitive
courant et et 2001
ce n'est que vers 2010 que les usagers
pourront s'envoler de notre dame des
landes à destination de l'asie ou les
états unis
autre action à nantes aujourd'hui autour
d'un projet qui concerne toute la région
où s je veux parler de l'implantation du
futur aéroport sur le site de notre dame
des landes en loire atlantique et
procédures sont désormais lancés mais
les opposants au choix de la plantation
l'aéroport ne désarment pas un millier
de personnes manifestaient cet après
midi à l'empt stéphanie pasgrimaud aussi
l'île du tout pourtant le projet
aéroportuaire notre dame des landes
prend de l'air le comité de pilotage va
passer au stade des études dès le début
de l'année 2004 une phase active qui ne
démobilise pas les opposants d'autres
projets par le passé ont été ont été
mises à mal par justement par la
population
je pense au carnet je pense
à d'autres à d'autres projets qui ont eu
ce même sort au delà de la dénonciation
qui concerne le déroulement du débat
public le millier de personnes est allée
au coeur de la ville pour toucher les
citadins le site est à 17 km de nantes
tous devraient se sentir concernés
sensibiliser les novices campos au
niveau financier
eux ils vont ils voir les retenues à
genoux de ce nouvel outil suspect c'est
clair que qui va payer
la question est quand même là
aujourd'hui les 14 associations
présentes s'accordent surtout à leur
place et des hommes au centre du projet
envisagé les impacts sur l'agriculture
il faire un choix pour l'environnement
de demain
si vous voulez une exploitation faut
qu'elle reste un noyau faut qu'elle
reste intacte à partir du moment qu'on
commence à lâcher un petit morceau de
ceci de cela on est on est plus en phase
par rapport aux directive nitrates par
rapport à nos plans d'épandage par
rapport à tout l'ensemble c'est à dire
que nos moyens de production sont
complètement diminué et moi les moyens
de production c'est mes revenus il faut
impérativement que ce soit beaucoup plus
réfléchie que ça après deux heures de
défilé le rassemblement s'est dispersé
tranquillement mais leur combat continue
le collectif n'a pas l'intention de
lâcher prise au lendemain des élections
le changement de majorité dans les pays
de la loire et en loire-atlantique
va-t-il remettre en question l'avenir de
gros dossiers
on pense notamment à celui du futur
aéroport de notre dame des landes
or qu'espèrent les opposants avec la
nouvelle donne politique réponse
olivier d'antin et luc prix c'est le
changement de majorité départementale et
régionale ne devrait pas perturber la
procédure en cours
hormis les verts le projet avait en
effet le soutien de la presque totalité
des partis politiques
toutefois les opposants n'ont pas perdu
tout espoir d'être entendu nous la cipa
nous avons toujours dit que la priorité
pour nous était la mobilisation des
populations
il n'empêche que nous souhaitons bien
entendu le soutien des élus et nous
l'avons toujours sollicité le résultat
des élections on montre qu' il y a des
leçons à retenir est que on devrait
écouter davantage
la population marcel verger maire de
bouvent et tout nouveau conseiller
général divers gauche de ce canton a été
élu pour ses prises de position contre
le projet aujourd'hui son discours
semble un peu plus nuancé cet aéroport
c'est comme un puzzle et on a une pièce
on voudrait le maître mais l'emplacement
est trop petit et et là il me semble
indispensable de prendre ça en corde et
devoirs avait à l'étude de se rendre
compte aussi c'est possible ou pas
possible et quel impact ça ça s'engagera
les verts qui ont pris position contre
le projet sont maintenant au pouvoir au
conseil régional avec les socialistes
certes ils sont minoritaires mais ce
dossier nécessitera beaucoup de
diplomatie et de dialogue entre les deux
formations les écologistes gardant
toujours l'espoir que le projet
n'aboutira pas un élément me lie
toutefois efficacement pour un nouvel
aéroport l'incident du dimanche 21 mars
un avion d'une compagnie égyptienne est
sorti de la trajectoire normale d'
approche de nantes atlantique et a frôlé
des immeubles au nord de la ville
montrant peut-être que les conditions de
sécurité sur l'actuel aéroport ne sont
plus suffisantes
l'aéroport de notre dame des landes
c'est ce que l'on peut appeler le
dinosaure des projets
politico-économique dans l'ouest voilà
plus de quarante ans que l'idée de
construire une nouvelle plate forme
aéroportuaire près de nantes est née au
début tout va vite en 1967 on parle pour
la première fois d'installer cette
structure à notre dame des landes
cinq ans plus tard le projet est lancé
et en 1974 une zone d'aménagement
différé est créé elle réserve
ils 225 hectares de terrain en prévision
des travaux
au départ on s'est dit on ont subi fait
c'est à dire que ce qui fait pas fait
pour beaucoup de gens soient faits dans
les années 70 fait que même s'il était
contre on peut par contre progressé
c'est ce que tout le monde leur
répondais et les gens avaient peur de
2,2 prononcés contre le projet
d'aéroport ensuite jusqu'au milieu des
années 90 le projet tombe aux oubliettes
et le transport aérien ne se développe
pas comme prévu alors qu'en 1972 on
tablait sur 5 à 9 millions de passagers
à nantes pour l'an 2000 en 2001 on
atteignait seulement la barre des 2
millions de passagers annuels
du coup lorsque le gouvernement annonce
la reprise du projet il y a 6 ans
certains restent sceptiques
bon c'est vrai que dossiers dorment et
puis maintenant ça se réveille à coup on
sait pas est ce que ces faits est-ce que
c'est parfait c'est peut-être joué
d'avancé
tout est joué d'avancé ce qui s'est dit
pendant le débat public de 2003 mais
alors que l' enquête d'utilité publique
va commencer
les opposants au projet ne désarment pas
ils espèrent un nouveau changement de
cap dans ce dossier où le temps joue en
leur faveur et du temps il leur en reste
l'ouverture de l'aéroport est prévu dans
le meilleur des cas entre 2013 et 2015
plus on reparle de l'aéroport de notre
dame des landes près de nantes les
opposants redoutent dans les prochaines
heures une nouvelle intervention des
forces de l'ordre pour les expulser
d'une ferme promise à la destruction
malongo ils se sont donnés rendez vous
tôt ce matin des militants déterminés à
empêcher la destruction de cette maison
située sur la zone d'aménagement du
projet d'aéroport pour rentrer dans ce
secteur il faut montrer patte blanche
les accès sont bloqués tous ici
redoutent une intervention des policiers
carrière le tribunal de nantes a ordonné
l'évacuation de cette maison pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de signes de
présence
policière là dans les environs mais à la
fois ça veut dire que s'ils viennent pas
aujourd'hui à viendront un autre jour
donc c'est pas forcément rassurant pour
le moment l'ambiance est donc bon enfant
mais la vigilance reste de mise
ces militants occupent cette maison de
cuisine semaine date du départ des
propriétaires légaux
cette ferme et un de leurs symboles pour
sa démolition signifierait le début des
travaux de l'aéroport est donc une
rupture de contrat moral avec le parti
socialiste
c'est à dire il n'y aura pas de travaux
pas de début de travaux avant la fin des
recours
il ya plein de recours encore il n'est
pas question que les travaux démarrent
et jouer sur les mots en disant que
détruire une maison ce n'est pas le
début des travaux c'est pour nous c'est
insensé
de son côté la préfecture a assuré que
cette procédure d'expulsion n'avait
aucun rapport avec le début des travaux
ce projet d'aéroport prévu pour être
achevé en 2017 est au point mort depuis
un an
[Musique]